quoi de neuf Sofia kazoo joue ils le font ils le
font une des choses que
j'aime vraiment dans le fait de jouer ce personnage est qu'il
est plongé dans ces
circonstances extraordinaires rétrécissant en volant sur des
fourmis entrant dans des royaumes quantiques et
des trucs potentiellement mortels une chose que
nous avons toujours  essayé de maintenir, c'est
de tout gérer avec un peu d'entre nous
comme quelques-uns, nous avons beaucoup de trucs
dans ce film que le public n'a jamais
vus auparavant, vous verrez une
action de taille fourmi et une action de taille géante et vous pouvez
voir  beaucoup d'action de taille différente
entre subtilement mais ils l'ont bien compris
et ensuite vous avez perdu quelqu'un que
nous n'avons jamais vu en action à l'écran et
c'est génial pour
comprendre comment elle bouge comment elle se bat comment elle
vole prêt gardez-le alors soit le blaster que
vous avez mentionné Chris est absolument le
bongo pom-pom wah Oh coz - Wow
il y a tellement d'action et les enjeux
sont si élevés
immédiatement à la minute où nous introduisons
le personnage de va au jeu
ch  anges
mais j'ai besoin de toi, tout ne
s'isole pas finalement avec Johnson, ne le
fais pas, n'arrête pas de déplacer
jahmai au-delà de son fantôme, tu vas
questionner désolé papa
toi